confession i don't need bug spray i just
need to talk one virgin to another
yeah what's up this whole trip
was supposed to be about me spending
some alone time with mike
now she's acting all weird about it and
i get
wanting to take things slow but i'm
starting to wonder if she's just
not that into me like physically
felix that's not true must be so much
simpler with two guys
ah don't be so short
are you stressed about having sex with
benji it's just
benji's had sex before and i have no
idea what i'm doing
like when it's two guys how do you know
who's supposed to do what
i don't know it's just straight people
grow up
seeing other straight people have snacks
in movies i didn't have that
unless you count porn which is usually
really fast and grunty and they're
always named kade oh yeah no no i'm okay
yeah he does straight porn too
i just really need a gay person to talk
me through this
simon leave a message
hey simon uh
sorry about all the texts and the dms
and
now this voicemail but if you could give
me a call back within the next 10
minutes and tell me everything i could
possibly need to know about
gay sex that would be great
oh this is victor by the way
hope you're well
you